i don't know why i always kind of like
that i don't know i i like the idea that
you're like it's like you feel this
change
i bet you have more appreciation for
your country yeah you know everybody's
going to do it
and it's it's what you do yeah there's
something about it that
also you travel also you have to go to
another country and see how other people
live plus you got to learn to work
you got to learn to work as a team and
just like your life depends on it you
get in shape
there are a lot of people that believe
in the draft i mean i'm i'm on the fence
about it i don't think it's a terrible
idea you can't do it now
you couldn't do it now there's no way to
do it vietnam changed
that was the last of the draft i believe
so well yeah my dad
just they stopped my dad's 65
and so he was they stopped it i think
the year before he was able to
that he would have been 18. oh god and
they stopped the draft
though those unless those enlisted in
the in the military is interesting
though because
there's got there's a ufc fighter named
korean zombie
he was in like the midst of his career i
was like sorry guys i'm gonna leave for
four years and go do this and i'll come
back
before he's back he's back yeah he's
awesome right yeah he's great yeah
remember
i mean uh he's just older so it's like
think about the older four years in your
ted williams uh for the uh red sox that
sucks yeah
i mean he went to war this dude it's so
crazy
like that stuff should be accounted for
as far as like records go
and they should be like and just a heads
up on these records he went to
war and came back and bought it and then
came back and like
they would pull them out of their i mean
it would be steph curry
wins mvp and then he goes to war for two
years like in the middle east yeah in
the middle east
then he comes back and he's like guys a
little bigger
to go to be drafted and they took six
years
six in his prime mind yeah six pretty
much
the amount of money he would make those
six years and he could have easily gone
and for two years and come back or even
a year because they would have worked
out a deal but he was
too extensive he was like no i'm not
doing it so they they said no vietcong
has ever called me the n-word yeah what
a price to pay like that's why he goes
on the greatest like i mean that's yeah
he actually gave something up
[ __ ] yeah gave up i mean six years yeah
six years
and he didn't know if he was going to be
able to come back that's like one of
those things where it's like in the
prime
prime of my life i'm going to stand for
this it's different time now like
no no guy nfl nba big time box and
at ufc would be like i'm gonna go leave
making all this money and do four years
in the military pat tillman did it
he was one of those he was one of the
ones that pat took a little different of
an animal right so september 11th
happened
he was you know all pro safety for the
cardinals was like oh i'm going to be a
special forces i'm be a ranger and
they're like okay
and then what's a bummer about his he
died from friendly fire yeah but there's
whole conspiracy with that
yeah that's a bummer yeah there's a
conspiracy behind that yeah
like like the guys were like jealous of
them because you know he had he just
went from the nfl and jumped right into
the special forces
and you know dies my friend yeah who
knows
isn't there a ufc fighter that either
went to war
kennedy oh no not besides him there was
another guy i thought like uh
that just korean zombie had to do like
you just said
two or three two two yeah yeah you think
are you thinking of a white guy
yeah yeah american tim was an operator
besides tim though there was
it was uh another guy other than tim
that i thought i saw that
was in the army that is a ufc fighter
now
well he was in the army yeah brian stan
brian stan was in the army well he
retired about nine years ago
um now no you're not no you're
neil magne was in the army he was a
medic in the army
it could be near but i thought he was a
white i thought it was a white guy i was
singing
i love if we're not nailing this guy
that's all right he's saying
trying to name the guys i thought it was
a white guy
i could be wrong i i don't know he's
like no
he was white i liked him
[Laughter]
i see where you're getting that
christian
[Laughter]
people want brian stan to be the uh
yeah randy couture was in brian stan
neil magne
look at tim's the face of so these are
all the us these guys this is a tour
it could be randy couture yeah oh you're
going old school i think you're talking
about current
no no no jesus christ dude yeah i'll
give you yeah randy couture
for sure awesome um tim is
tim tim was literally doing i think
secret mission he still is wow
crush dude i invite i go hey dude you
wanna go on food truck because he's flew
in he's on
my show food truck diaries tomorrow he
[ __ ] goes yeah i'm in send me a
picture a helicopter
full camo i'm like where are you going
he's like talk to you later
like jesus christ and i called him and
he answered i'm such a puss i wouldn't
this is how he answered the phone i
called him up and i just get this i go i
can't phone
i just hear this he just goes america
yeah he's the best what was he shooting
hogs or something
uh terrorist
yeah no is he invited he invited brennan
you know he said to us he's not my thing
do you guys want to get on horseback and
kill hogs with a spear tomorrow no
but then he goes through those i'll rent
us a helicopter shoot him out of the
helicopter like yeah i know they do that
that's not my fault
yeah it's not what i did but yeah you
would do it yeah 100
there's no way i would do that and i
want to do it
no but we have to shoot like white
rhinos or something overdo the cove
you know he has to be an endangered
animal yeah people hate hunger but
they couldn't know they could shoot the
hospital out there it's right there
because they're passed
tim were talking to killing them for
sure he's like do you know what they do
brendan like i have no clue dude
i love first of all i love pork second
of all i would shoot the [ __ ] out of all
the hogs have you hunted anything
yes are you a hunter nate i'm not really
yeah
you know maybe it's your boy yeah that's
the accent southern
you know i just assume you hunt no yeah
my dad no we
we didn't grow up with any of that stuff
like i had buddies they did i had
buddies that would
you know if a deer got hit by a car
they'd pull over and it was
recent enough fresh yeah fresh enough
they just put them back a truck
and you grew up in uh old hickory yeah
it's like a suburb of nashville
and you love about them yeah i love it
i'm back then we've
been back uh five six years something
like that uh it's the best
nashville's i'm a big big obviously a
nashville fan nashville has
changed so much from when i was there
when i was a kid
blowing up everybody's moving there
everybody's moving there it's uh
downtown has gotten pretty crazy i mean
we never went downtown a ton but uh
it's gotten just so it's a whole nother
vibe kind of down there